closer framework see is you clarify why
the person is there what made you get on
the call what's your goal why is that
important to you what would it look like
12 months from now if this ideal outcome
where do it be achieved next you label
them with a problem so what i'm hearing
is
you've done x y and z and the missing
link has been
x is that right
yes got it i now have a problem you know
i have cancer i can cure it we're gonna
overview the pain so what have you done
in the past i've done x y and z why did
that not work for you obviously it
didn't work because they're on the phone
with you you do that until they have
nothing left and you're like awesome and
then you recap the pain yes sell the
vacation there's gonna be three stories
that you're gonna tell them they're
gonna be illustrative of the thing that
you were helping them solve an example
would be fitness nutrition and
accountability if i was trying to sell
weight loss you're usually missing one
or two or all three of these things
that's why you weren't successful
explain away their concerns think about
it i have to talk to my husband i have
to check with my partner you need to
overcome them last one to reinforce the
decision people back out how can we slam
it on them how can we get them super
pumped that's the closer framework every
single one of these buckets has to be
questions that are simple for them to
ask